bien messieurs type race nous avons des
positions radicalement sur toute une
série de sujets c'est un fait mais nous
partageons le désir de rendre la parole
au peuple contre la dictature européiste
et technocratique et nous nous sommes
donc très légitimement réjoui de
l'organisation du référendum ce
référendum en grèce sur l'austérité
signe le retour du politique dans son
sens le plus noble au sens au sein d'une
union européenne souvent réduite à des
attitudes technocratique les
institutions européennes et c'est peut
être un point positif ont montré leur
vrai visage
l'horreur l'horreur elles ont tout tenté
pour gagner ce référendum il y a eu de
multiples pressions morales détenant
l'autorité prédisant une catastrophe
en cas de non nous connaissons ce à nous
peuple français nous avions vécu la même
chose au moment de la campagne sur la
constitution européenne
le président du parlement ici à six a
même osé appeler à un renversement de
votre gouvernement monsieur type race
légitimement élu par le peuple
afin de le remplacer par un gouvernement
de technocrates les pays de la zone euro
ont tenté en vain d'empêcher la
publication jeudi du rapport du fmi sur
la dette de la grèce ce rapport
reprenait en effet vos arguments il faut
bien l'admettre et estime que la grèce
ne peut pas rembourser la dette
car cette dette est insoutenable et doit
donc être renégociés enfin la banque
centrale européenne a tenté de semer
l'effroi en asphyxiant les banques
grecques et en provoquant leur fermeture
temporaire je crois que c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'une
banque centrale crée de toutes pièces
une crise de manière absolument
artificiel mais la colère du peuple grec
envers la politique européenne d'hyper
austérité était telle que toutes les
manoeuvres ont été balayés par la
ferveur populaire
par delà les menaces le peuple grec a
repoussé le chemin sans espoir ni
perspective de l'union européenne
mais quel peuple aurait accepté pendant
cinq ans ce qu'a vécu le peuple grec bon
sens lesquels auraient accepté cela
messieurs
du ppe et les libéraux qui ont applaudi
frénétiquement le réquisitoire de
monsieur webber vous accepteriez vous de
faire campagne
vous êtes d'accord avec ça mais fait
donc campagne en promettant aux peuples
à vos peuples respectifs 25% de baisse
des salaires 25% de baisse des pensions
mais pète compagnon proposons un mot
peuple kremlin l'explosion de la
mortalité infantile la multiplication
par trois du sommeil soyez courageux
assumez vos positions ça n'est pas ce
que vous faites quand vous êtes en
campagne électorale
alors monsieur tsipras ce jeudi prince
laurent et l'austérité sont des frères
siamois
elle est là la réalité et vous ne
pourrez pas faire échapper votre peuple
à l'austérité
si vous ne lui permet pas d'échapper à
l'euro moi ce que je pense et que la
grèce doit en accord avec les
institutions européennes de manière
concertée tranquillement organisé sortir
de cette m'asseoir de fer que représente
l'euro pour l'ensemble des pays du sud
tous les peuples européens auraient
alors les yeux fixés sur la grèce et
pourrait vérifier que la sortie de
l'euro perd mais bien le renouveau et le
retour d'une croissance durable
c'est bien ça ce que disait monsieur
krug man prix nobel d'économie ce dont
vous avez peur messieurs de l'as des
institutions européennes ça n'est pas
que la grèce fasse faillite ce dont vous
avez peur c'est que la grèce en sortant
de l'euro démontre que l'on peut s'en
sortir mieux 100euros qu'avec le voile
se déchire
l'euro n'est pas irréversible c'est ce
que vous nous aviez vendu pendant des
années
l'euro c'est pour toujours et ben non
l'euro ça n'est pas pour toujours
l'euro n'est pas irréversible la
première crise de l'euro et et
financière et a été stoppée par la bce
en 2012 la deuxième crime et permet
politique ne vous en déplaise
avec des peuples qui osent dire non et
vous ne pourrez pas celle-là la stopper
après tant d'erreurs il est largement
temps de dissoudre de manière concertée
la zone euro de conserver l'euro comme
monnaie commune les économies des pays
d'europe se porteront mieux et les
tensions entre les peuples s'apaiseront
enfin